Senate Minority
Leader, the
Republican, Mitch
McConnell,
says he is fine after a truly
unnerving movement on Capitol Hill.
On camera
this afternoon,
McConnell
stopped speaking
for some 30 seconds
right in the middle of remarks
at his regularly scheduled
news conference.
Here is that moment
After finishing
the NDAA,
this week has been
good bipartisan cooperation
and a string of
stuff that
Senator Clinton said during the show.
To make this change.
Anything else you want to say?
I'm sure to go back to
do you want to say anything else
to the press?
John Dickerson,
let's go back to you.
Go ahead, John.
Quite a concerning moment there.
CNN's Michael Rogers on Capitol Hill.
He was there as it was happening.
And want to understand.
You spoke to the senator
himself afterwards.
What did he say to you?
Yeah,
he didn't really
get into the details about what happened.
I tried to ask him about that
very unnerving moment
that alarmed his colleagues
that sent Senator McConnell
away from this weekly press conference.
He walked over to his office,
which is a short walk
from where that press conference was.
And then he later returned
and answered questions from reporters
like me
when I asked him about this
and whether he can continue
to do his job.
He indicated he could
Could you address what happened here
at the start of the press conference
and it was related to your
injury from earlier this year
where you suffered a concussion.
Is that going to
define your fully able to, you know,
do your job, you know, later tonight
Now, McConnell aide
told me
that the leader
at that moment felt lightheaded.
And then he came back
and he answered questions over.
It's about five questions
or so
on a range of issues, ranging
from impeachment to the Hunter Biden
plea deal that collapsed.
But there have been a number of questions
about McConnell's health
since earlier this year
when at the age of 81
he fell and hit his head
at a Washington hotel during an event.
He later suffered a concussion
as well as
sustained fractures to his ribs.
He when he went to the hospital
for some time,
he was out of the Senate
for several weeks later returned.
He has been walking,
tends to walk
gingerly it's been that way for some time
because he suffered polio as a kid.
He walks with a slight limp.
But in recent years,
he has had incidents where he has fallen.
And the most recent one, of course,
causing a lot of concerns
about his health.
Now, there was another situation
a couple of months ago
when at the same weekly press conference
that he has,
he couldn't hear reporters questions
who were clearly audible.
The questions were very audible.
They were nearby.
He had a difficult time hearing.
And in another situation
that's raising questions
about his health.
Now, McConnell
indicating that he's not going anywhere,
that he plans to serve out
at least
through the end of this Congress.
He's not up for reelection again
until 20, 26
he has not made any announcements
about whether you try
to become leader again
in the next Congress
or whether he'd run for reelection again.
But this will only add to questions
about his future
in this very unnerving moment.
Jim.
Manu Raju on the Hill, thanks so much.
So let's put some of those questions
to Dr.
Sanjay Gupta.
Dr.
Gupta, I always hesitate to ask you
to diagnose from afar,
but this is your field.
And I wonder, as you saw that
really heart wrenching.
30 some seconds there of that pause,
freezing up.
What struck you as significant
Well, that was concerning.
There's no no question about it.
And I
and I think
he's going to need a thorough examination
and workup.
And I'm sure his doctors
will probably look at that clip
just to sort of
try and
figure out what exactly happened there.
I think, you know,
I mean, there's all sorts of things
that that come to mind.
But as you correctly point out, Jim,
some of those things will will
become clearer
once he gets a more thorough examination.
Common things being common.
You have to wonder
if someone is dehydrated.
Did they?
Is this some kind of medication
side effect?
But also, you know,
more seriously,
was this a petite mal seizure?
A mini seizure,
so to speak,
or even a transient ischemic attack?
A sort of mini stroke?
Again, that's speculation.
And, you know, but but it's interesting.
Manu asked that question.
I was just looking at the clock
for about 23 seconds.
He was standing at the lectern
before someone asked if he was okay.
And then it was 32 seconds
when he sort of walked off.
When he was walking off,
he was moving his arms and his legs.
Okay.
So that was a good sign
that what had happened
seemed like it had started to resolve
and then I think it was about 12 minutes
later when Manu asked him that question.
And he sort of said he was doing okay.
But clearly something happened there.
You have to
you have to assume common
things are common, first of all.
But you do have to also rule out
potentially more serious things.
And he needs an exam. He needs.
He says he's fine.
But he needs to get checked out clearly.
I asked Monitor
that if he got an immediate exam.
To his knowledge, he did not.
I think when I'm thinking of older
relatives, for instance,
see the acronym right. Be fast, right.
You look at various symptoms.
If, for instance, that were a stroke.
Balance eye movement face, droopy bit.
But a key part of it.
Right, is is quick a quick assessment.
If a relative of yours,
say, or a patient of yours
exhibited such symptoms,
you would recommend that they see
they seek medical care
or at least an assessment right away.
Absolutely.
I mean, time is is critically important.
Again, I don't want to overstate this,
you know,
and be careful in terms
of how we're presenting this.
But but I think that
there was clearly
some sort of neurological event
that happened there,
whether it was just
because of
dehydration, or medication
or something like that, perhaps.
But that was, again.
23 seconds before he was asked
if he was okay.
32 seconds before he left the lectern
they watched closely.
Again, he was doing it of his own power,
you know, so
he talked about that acronym.
One of the things they're testing for
is strength.
And it appeared that he had strength on
both the right and left side of his body.
But but a mini seizure, a mini stroke,
or again, something more common,
whatever it is that needs to be assessed.
So
I'm hoping that his staff is getting him
to the hospital to get that checked out.